Listen, where we are with science and
technology is a completely contingent
matter. I mean, there's nothing inevitable
about it. The Industrial Revolution: why
would it happen - who would have predicted
it would happen in some grisly, rainy
bits of North England in the 18th
century? Well, there was coal elsewhere.
And it could have happened anywhere. It
happened there. That's one of those frail
constructs that...So the other thing—just
to come back to my story about people
staying standing in line for an iPhone 4—
is that I was quite interested in
technologies that we all take for
granted, then become very grubby, you know.
So, it is an absolute miracle to fly from
San Diego to San Francisco in an hour
and a half. But it's just such a drag.
Luggage carousel, the security. Oh yes, you
can see the clouds in the Ventana
wilderness. But you know, that's just the
way in which an iPhone—smartphone— ends
up in your sock drawer or in the
hands of your grandchildren discarded. So
in this world I wanted the grubby
reality with the future poured
into it. So you could have 400 mile-an-
hour trains on, you know, levitated by
magnetic force, zipping you from San
Francisco to  LA.  But it'd be
crowded and dirty and noisy, and the
windows will be filthy, and it will just
be another bore of the, you know, the necessary
things of life. And you can't check in
your luggage, you have to heave it up
under the rug luggage rack yourself. And
it's that rub off of when the
shiny future arrives, it rapidly absorbs
itself into our endlessly untidy bedroom,
as it were, our teenage bedroom of social
reality. That's what fascinates me.
When messy humans get their shiny new
toys, the shine goes off very quickly.